if I sit down to Thanksgiving table with
my family and friends and there are no
latkes then I'm probably just gonna run
to the grocery store grab some potatoes
come on back and make them for everybody
you
my name is Jared Muller and I'm a chef
here in New York City I'm not totally
sure a hundred percent on where latkes
came from I believe they are from Europe
Ashkenazi Jewish cuisine I know that
throughout several generations in my
family it's something that has always
been a mainstay in special occasions in
cooking it's like a very comforting
feeling to have a lot because we would
kind of do a Thanksgiving Hanukkah
mashup so it kind of evokes wonderful
memories of being together with the
family and friends
I think food can definitely be used to
tell a story and pass on heritage and
traditions altogether I did just have a
baby and he's about two weeks old
there's nothing I look forward to more
than getting in the kitchen and passing
on that recipe and those traditions you
know I would like to instill that food
and family together is very strong thing
here in our household and going on and
just kind of passing the torch if you
will for him to make latkes for me
someday
you